i'm looking at my hands and my arm
i don't know if i'm entitled to get the
coronavirus vaccine
i i think i'm technically white i
because of my southern italian ancestry
sicilian i'm a little swarthier you know
maybe this will bump me a little further
up the line
to get the vaccine because the vaccine
is not going to be
given out based on your age it's not
going to be given out based on your risk
factors for catching this virus it's not
even going to be given out based on your
professional risk factors it's going to
be given out
whether you're in a favored race or a
disfavored race
and according to the new york times if
you're white
according to these public health experts
at harvard and all of these elite
institutions
if you're white you don't deserve the
vaccine and the premise here is that
you're all we're all going to die from
coronavirus it's so super duper
dangerous
that you got to lock yourself in your
room we have to wait for the vaccine so
what they are saying the the experts and
the media they're saying
that if you're white you deserve to die
you don't
you don't be because of historical
injustice that's the catch-all phrase
you don't deserve to have this
life-saving
vaccine i have questions about how
deadly the virus really is we were told
initially that you know this was
extraordinarily deadly then we have
studies that show
99.7 survival rates so got questions
about that got some questions about the
vaccine
but nonetheless according to their
premise that is
the new american caste system and the
cdc is backing it up
according to the daily mail the cdc has
quote advised states to consider ethnic
minorities as a critical and vulnerable
group in their vaccine
distribution plans this is already in
effect half of the nation states
have have plans that prioritize black
hispanic and indigenous residents over
white people in some way as the vaccine
rolls out
according to the daily mails analysis 25
states
have committed to focus on racial and
ethnic communities
but only obviously not all everyone has
a race everyone has an ethnicity
so only some favored racial and ethnic
communities
as they decide which groups should be
prioritized in receiving
a coronavirus vaccine dose this is
absolutely disgusting
this is against the law this is criminal
the people who are putting this into
effect
should be brought up on charges for it
it's absolutely outrageous
they won't be because no matter how much
you hear the left talk about
color blindness racial justice racial
equality
they don't want that at all what they
want
is a sort of inv what you would call
inverted racism it's just racism it's
just bigotry
that uh disfavors white people and asian
people who now by the way for
uh many institutions are being counted
as white people i don't know how they
they had that uh unfavorable title
voiced upon them but that's where we
stand
and they would favor other races now
this is so disgusting
this is so vile and anti-american that
the cdc
is walking this back so after the hubbub
over all of this
they said that okay now americans over
75
should be able to get the vaccine along
with the essential frontline workers
and the favored races which is an
improvement i suppose but it's still not
enough we know that people who are 65 to
75
are at a higher risk than frontline
workers generally
but if you're 65 to 75 and you're white
then you're you're not permitted to get
it according to these reports according
to the cdc
does not fully address the issue now
it's very easy to say that this is
hypocrisy
right and i think most of the
conservative criticism of these
disgusting policies is that it's
hypocrisy
it's actually not hypocrisy to use a
phrase from the great harvard law
professor adrian vermuel
when the left does all these kinds of
crazy things
it's not hypocrisy it's hierarchy
the left you know we always talk about
well the tolerant left or well you know
the race blind left or whatever
when i listen to leftists today
they don't really talk about tolerance
all the time at least not in the way we
understand it they're not really talking
about racial equality in the way that
conservatives would talk about it
they are actively coming out and saying
no we need to
prioritize certain favored groups over
other favored groups
we don't want equality we don't want
fairness we want
a kind of reverse caste system
for the alleged historical injustices
that's that isn't hypocrisy to to give
the devils their due
to give the leftists their due they are
explicitly saying yeah white people have
had too many advantages
so now we're going to give them
disadvantages even if that means that
you've got this vaccine that we're all
telling you is very very important to
get
well you're not getting it too bad
that's because of your
race now the cdc is walking this back
because it's just too far even for
for where the country is right now but
all it is doing
is testing the limits of ideology right
all it's doing is seeing how far can we
push our racial
grievance or politics
[Music]
[Music]